it's really not going well for
Republican congressman Devin Nunez he
had to step down from his role chairing
the house investigation into Trump
Russia
he got caught running to the White House
to tell Trump what the investigation was
doing he made a huge deal out of this
now infamous memo that turned out to be
completely unremarkable in every way he
got caught running his own fake news
website the California Republican and
now we've learned that Devin Nunez is
being investigated for possible campaign
finance law violations the FEC sent him
a letter this week saying that there are
three contributions that he received
from individuals possibly illegal
contributions and that an investigation
is now ongoing there are three people
their names aren't important they're not
super relevant who appear to have
donated more than the maximum $2,700 per
donor per election cycle to Devin Nunez
there's also a fourth donation for
$10,000 which is raising red flags
because it came from a company called
stone land company and the FEC law
doesn't allow contributions from
companies or labor organizations
unless made from separate segregated
funds established by the corporation or
labor organization sort of technical
doesn't even really matter the details
of but the point is that after 18 months
of public embarrassment and face
planting by Nunez now he's dealing with
a federal probe into his campaign
finances and has about a month to
respond to that probe and the other
funny little detail that I fed that I
sort of picked up or noticed reading the
stories about this is that Devin knew
neces mom is his campaign treasurer I
mean I guess it sort of makes sense if
you're running like for City Council in
a small city but is it normal for your
mom to be the treasurer of your campaign
for US Congress as a sitting congressman
I maybe it's because Trump sets the
nepotism standards and now it becomes a
nepotism all the way down and they're
all doing this thing maybe I'm wrong and
it's not that rare that at the national
level you want someone in there that you
trust and I guess presumably most people
can trust their moms but there's
something about
especially with new nests that seems a
little bit odd to me and I don't know in
the end who if anybody is gonna end up
in jail or in prison as a result of the
Trump administration's actions and their
involvement with it but if people do end
up doing time I kind of hope new Ness is
one of those people obviously if he did
illegal things I'm not saying someone
who did nothing wrong should be put in
jail or prison but if he is one of the
people that behaved incorrectly I would
like to see him actually face the
consequences for it and the other part
of this that just sort of I guess
disappointing is that of all the garbage
that Nunez has been involved in for
sketchy donations is the only thing
that's actually being investigated that
that just kind of bums me out in a way
but I guess it's something but big
picture I'm increasingly I mentioned
this earlier with Jeff Sessions and his
perjury earlier in the week I'm
increasingly kind of preparing myself
for the reality that a lot of these
people are going to get away completely
without consequences and the fact that
of everything that Nunez has been
involved in what they're looking into is
for donations made to his re-election
campaign
I'm not feeling hugely optimistic that
we're going to see real consequences
here well if there is any recourse it's
that he's a congressman which means that
he's up for re-election in November of
this year yeah and given the fact that
he's jumped onto the national stage and
people in Fresno know about him
you know ranks the White House to update
the White House on the source of the
intelligence or you know the memo gate
stuff or now these campaign finance
violations they could be incentivized to
vote him out I would love that would be
the best thing right just vote this guy
out vote him out in November because all
of these people men and women are up for
re-election every two years that's why
they're campaigning all the time because
one election finishes and then five
months later they're already campaigning
and raising money for their next
election that's the opportunity which is
aside from whatever happens with this
investigation
you can vote this guy out although we'll
see if California actually decides to do
it the video you just watched was made
possible by support from you please go
to patreon.com slash david pakman show
you can make a pledge of as little as $1
per month
and every dollar helps to support the
work that we're doing particularly in
light of the YouTube ad boycott which
has been really bad